the government is in your pants no
really it's in your pants thanks to
smartphones it's easier than ever to get
tracked so artists designers and
scientists are all fighting back with
what's known as stealth fashion and it's
going global a Brooklyn artist created a
hoodie and visor that use reflective and
metallic fabrics to shield your face
from camera drones flying overhead he
also came up with counter-surveillance
makeup designs to throw off facial
recognition software scientists in Tokyo
have countered facial recognition
software with glasses using infrared
light then there's a london-based
clothing company that designed an entire
fashion line that blocks cell phone
Wi-Fi GPS and RFID tracking and there
are a bunch of cell phone pouches on the
market to keep unwanted interception out
but while counter-surveillance fashion
grows let's not forget the traditional
gear